oh [__] it's the [__] Lord's Day
[__] strap one on you little
dirty [__] Jesus died for your sins
[Music]
there you go coming through the [__]
airwaves
ain't no podcast this is just you and I
having a [__] chitchat about the
upcoming week nobody gets their feelings
hurt you filthy [__] get that bun ready
get the heroin pills ready
you get grandpa's chemo pills I don't
give a [__] what you need to do we're
going deep deep deep
into the murky waters of the underworld
we got a little bit of [__] Obama
weed we got everything today he's gonna
pop we got some [__] TKO is to get
the Lord's based on forget about it you
better get your [__] together
[Music]
so beautiful [__] day to be
alive uncle Joey here from the office
the birds are chirpin the sun's out my
hemorrhoids gone and it's a new [__]
week [__] you understand me strap
on your [__] seatbelts it's the first
week of May Saturday Mexicans will be
jumping up and down
Cosby's going to jail [__] David
Copperfield is on [__] trial what's
the world coming to
that's why you got to get your [__]
bong hit from time to time and soothing
off the whole brain cuz we can't handle
this [__] don't come game is hanging out
in North Korea everybody what we've got
a [__] crazy here
but listen who needs social commentary
when you got the [__] mule right here
you understand me and the little mule
this is the one forget it to them banned
in 11 countries that's how good this
[__] bong is banned in 11 countries
people see spots Chinese kids can't take
it no more
we got a little [__] [__] clown
jumble Joey you gotta show up with some
[__] heat I'm saying we got a podcast
tonight we got another podcast Wednesday
and Thursday [__] strap on your seat
belt Arizona uncle Joey's coming to town
if you're from Mexico City jump the war
[__] we're going now [__] heavy you
understand me
grenades bazookas I got some of Pablo
Escobar's old weed we're going [__]
beep in Tempe Arizona you got a show
Thursday you got two shows fried and you
got to show Saturday and it won't be
tickets left for long so do what the
[__] you gotta do [__] I don't
wanna hear you hit me up Friday uncle
Joey I forgot a little bad I don't give
a [__] if you sleep you're [__] done
cut boots buddy wait I'm to brighter
horizons it's a beautiful day to be
alive sit down write your goals for the
week whatever happened last week go [__]
themselves it's a whole new week [__]
if your sub played this last week this
week you won't suck mud it's that type
of [__] month it's May first
[__] taxes are paid you're
ready to go and it's a whole new [__]
week but Joey enough give me a [__]
bong aroun in here let's do it
I got some tremendous weed from the
[__] sunset herbal aka the Armenians
oh [__] and it's glow-in-the-dark just
in case there's an earthquake and you
get stuck in the basement you can always
find you a little canister a weed you
understand me you think you're like why
is it so why me because we [__] plan
ahead here there's an earthquake I'll
find the weed I got the lightest Scotch
taped to my thigh I'm ready to [__]
go along I'm like Rambo remember when he
got caught up in the mountains of
Portland he found the match what the
[__] mines and finds a match in the coal
mine Rambo I had a match and they lit
the gasoline and they [__] got out
but anyway that's a completely my right
side inside oh sure they can't find it I
think it's you dick if they touch it you
know Santi well enough is enough enough
with the Harvey our here it's a whole
new week it's a whole new set of rules
and the best thing is you [__] write
the rules you give a figure that out
that you write the rules not they do you
write the [__] rules it's
world [__] they're busy if we don't
think that way you're already taken in
the ass by society people avoid them you
see that they know the streets his own
Johnny blade Black Sabbath never-say-die
1978 their last album is [__] Black
Sabbath what are you gonna do we got the
blizzard of aahhhs we got [__] hot
every any editor who gives a [__] Joey
Kendall Barnett oh well I still [__]
money there why are we getting together
for when I gotta do it Bonnie what's she
doing if she's not gonna cook him same
look at Lee he's single his head's
already [__] he's ready to [__] go
for a single woman leaves ready to sling
some dick honey he's got some Nazi sperm
with that little Jude thing ready to go
I'm saying
tremendous research they've had this
Obama since I lived in Hollywood and
they've just grown on it and growing on
it and running
same [__] strain and now it's deadly
you understand me they get this once a
[__] year this Obama oh because the
guys that on sunset arable used to own
the [__] weed store on sunset next to
[__] uh rouse rock n roll Rob's the
fat little [__] chick that that
little [__] Russian in there god damn
that [__] is bangin and when she was
fat she bumped it but then she lost
weight she forgot about it she thought
you but she was a badass [__] she lost
that big ass anyway who gives a [__]
yeah she want to talk to me no more when
she got skinny can you imagine that [__]
fat [__] anyway I love your
[__] who gives a [__] Lee
what's with the questions Obama flat if
it was mrs. Obama it's not like [__]
feet or something I don't [__] know
you know I love MS o mom I gotta bring
him up for I love MS Obama
bring back my [__] Melania bring back
mrs. Obama with that big black ass and
those [__] ooh I'd eat that [__]
monkey like a savage mrs. Obama I'd pull
out that [__] Chinese hair she
wouldn't know what it that's Chinese
head three chicks died for mrs. Obama's
hairdo
there's three chinks walking around and
[__] China with no hair and mrs.
Obama's out shaking hands and waving a
pen
oh [__] will come and deep at you this
afternoon
a little Johnny blade listen I know I
know I've been off for a few days I've
been busy I can't be doing these
periscopes every [__] day because you
guys got lies who the [__] am i I'm just
a [__] fact Amelia I can't keep
tormenting you we get together once or
twice a week and that's good you have
together once or twice a week with you
regular alright then what the [__] you
young people don't live with you does he
does he pop up every time he's got a
[__] joint if he does he's [__]
creepy me I show up you don't even know
what I'm showing up it's like I'm
[__] surprised it's like a cherry on
the sundae let's smoke a bowl with uncle
Joey bus stop the [__] grenade
[__]
a couple more buglets I'll let you go
back to your usual [__] take that
thing from right now your uncle Joey
don't forget you bad [__] Tempe
and the party starts Thursday night
listen to do that kidnapped is showing
up Cantrell is showing up 10th planet
[__] Phoenix John Paul Towers showing
up NIC gregarious is showing up the
jujitsu do listen get ready to get down
if you come Friday night I'll have the
guy kidnapped give me an autograph you
following me who's better than that the
guy uncle Joey kidnapped is giving you a
[__] autograph huh thirty years ago
who's better than your uncle Joey
there's always I'm like a fat [__]
Cuban fortune cookie anyway I smoked the
[__] another Bowl here and I said I'll
let you guys be you're nice people did
you go to church today me neither
I'm my own idea I slept though eight
eleven [__] Church you don't say I'm not
catching a 10 o'clock on with all those
pedophiles you have two kids with the
missing leg I got a feel bad
[__] you I go to 7:30 with the pens gee
what
ah now that's a [__] Sunday you
follow me
anybody get to come over potato salad
[__] you show up with a [__] G bowl
of some [__] Russian artillery
let's take Cuomo bomber he's insane
everybody throws Trump under the bus I
mean I don't vote I don't give a [__]
about nobody I don't give a [__] about
who's president who's finally even know
vice presidents and do I give a [__]
listen when I'm at [__] the
supermarket buying groceries there ain't
nobody there but me
you follow me and that's all that
matters we got to put this deal [__]
together here Oh BAM what are you
[__] nuts
oh shut up
[__] you smoke whatever they give
you you smoke what they give you
understand me who gives a [__] the felon
Pete it was high-powered Pete besides I
would be that time my [__] when my bud
selling the weed that I had a brother
[__] weed and I found the [__]
beats at old when I was pissing and all
the weed half of it like it didn't get
wet except for one [__] bud and I put
it in the shelf and let it dry for like
a month whatever was in my piss and the
strength of that weed I brought it into
this office we smoked it we could even
see that [__] night nobody could see
nothing nobody knew nothing I don't know
nothing uncle Joey I'm [__] high as
[__] we got mad I smoked pee who gives a
[__] you got a smoke good evening time
to time what do you mean you ain't smart
never smokers you don't show up a weed
that's what happens I'm sure when I show
up a wee there's always a [__]
surprise you don't know if I dip it in
something you ready for another bong
let's do it well do another bong and I
will get you I promise y'all go get you
an ice cream sundae
let's do another couple of buckets what
do you say people whether you got to do
I got some [__] Johnny [__] are
you nuts
and you [__] nuts anyway let's do a
bumper I'm a little [__] up this weed
is tremendous I'm Tanya don't you think
I would show up with bogus weed you take
our show up for the [__] Susquehanna
Fugazi that's not my stuff that's not my
[__] spiel oh you know I'm saying
[Music]
that's what you do on Sundays you hang
out with Uncle you do a couple [__]
bong hits oh [__] then you get a little
hot dog or Sunday what with all the pain
I watched you live with him
I'm seeing [__] you ever see [__] in the
afternoon I saw him feeling last night a
nice time at the Comedy Store he came
down nice for the show Tomi Rose was
down at Dahmer era I was home by 10:30
tip-top Magoo and bed by quarter to
11:00 understand me but then I woke up
at 3:00 hungry as a [__]
somebody gave me an elephant economy's
go I had a kid open I got a pen an apple
and a [__] Weight Watchers protein
bar 2.7 grams of protein as much as a
[__] egg do the man
[Music]
I always have watch the boys know know
how I put them on today puts two points
that was it I gave three points of
peanut
we think one more one more [__]
you know I love you [__] I'll
tell you something this week but I'll
tell you the latter part of the week I
got something for you Sam you know how
we roll
I'm no [__] Sunday with it I thought
he wants is a [__] Sunday this kid
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
that's what Sunday's are about now you
go home to your families eat a beautiful
[__] Sunday dinner with your family
your kids say the prayers it's over
tomorrow you wake up like a [__]
savage and heat ready to go stab a
[__] there it's Monday you get a
second chance to be an animal all over
again every [__] Monday the rest is
up to you [__] me I got a full
[__] squeak don't ask one thing I know
for sure is I'm getting on that plane
and I'm going to [__] tempt you with
my man D'Agostino and we're rocking you
[__] out like I said if you
want to meet the kidnappee stop by and
say hello take a picture and beside that
who's better than you [__]
nobody cuz you're the church they want
to be with you you want to be with me
and they want to be with us think of
suck our dick and call it shorty those
[__] what were they when we had
[__] we were struggling nowhere now
they can suck our [__] balls that's
right anyway I don't know if you like
your balls suck I'm just [__] saying
maybe you don't like your balls so maybe
I'm out of line here who gives a [__]
uncle Joey coming at you we'll see you
guys tonight
6 o'clock Pacific 9 o'clock Eastern
that's the [__] phrase right there
Church what's happening now coming at
you you bad [__] I love you
go give your families a hug and stay
black all right cuz at the end of your
day that's all you got is your [__]
family see you later